China's central bank plans to replace
its cash with an alternative a digital
version of its national currency think
of it like cash but only on your phone a
cryptocurrency that's issued by the
People's Bank of China and backed by the
renminbi a new global currency after
Facebook announced the launch of its own
cryptocurrency the central bank
accelerated its work China is already
well on its way to becoming a cashless
society over 600 million Chinese almost
half the country already use apps such
as Ali Baba's Ali pay and $0.10 WeChat
to pay for everything from groceries to
bike rentals today the two companies
handle close to 90 percent of China's
third-party mobile payments market the
central bank's currency will provide a
new payment tool to substitute cash
unlike alley pay or WeChat users won't
be limited to paying within one platform
China plans for its crypto to be
accepted by any individual or
institution just like banknotes and
coins if Beijing's plans materialize
China could become the first major
nation to go completely cash free and
that could reverberate across the global
financial system if it succeeds I would
expect that a large number of other
countries will want to emulate their
success there is still little known
about how the system known as digital
currency electronic payments or dcep
will operate and what it will look like
so we examined official statements and
documents to understand why China is
pushing hard into this crypto future
this is mode Chun Chun he oversees the
central bank's digital currency efforts
and is the country's most outspoken
authority on the roll out since August
he has given a number of speeches on
China's digital yuan and even launched
an online course about Facebook's Libre
on a popular Chinese education app
facebook's plans to provide its two
billion users with a brand-new digital
currency spooked central banks around
the world including china's AC that
Lieber could be a way of extending
American financial germany into the
digital currency space as well say
helping to implement sanctions and
export controls Beijing historically saw
D central
digital currencies like Bitcoin as a
threat to a long-standing pillar of its
monetary policy capital control but then
in October Chinese President Xi Jinping
spoke about the important role a
blockchain endorsing the government's
embrace of the technology that powers
cryptocurrencies they're looking at this
and saying is there some element of it
that we like and actually what they
found is that blockchain is an excellent
technology for tracking that could give
an unprecedented level of power for any
central bank in the world over capital
movements
officials say the digital currency will
not challenge alley pay and WeChat but
it would have some similarities like
WeChat and alley pay it will need a
digital wallet but unlike the paying
platforms it won't require a bank
account instead commercial banks will
issue the digital wallets a unique
aspect of China's crypto will be that
payments can be conducted offline so in
case of a natural disaster when the
network is down or if you're on board a
plane you can still pay as long as your
phone has power and authorities promise
a major difference will be greater
anonymity but it won't be absolute
anonymity this patent filed by the
central bank in 2017 shows that it's
researched ways to track digital cash
marketers won't know what people spend
their money on but that information will
still be visible to the central bank to
a certain extent one of the most
interesting aspects of the system is how
much data will the central bank have
about where things go because that's one
of the largest most important
differences between digital currency in
cash the central bank calls this
controllable anonymity and says big data
can help identify certain behavioral
characteristics
officials say tracking transactions will
help battle money laundering tax evasion
and terrorist financing which is harder
to do with cash transactions and while
the central bank says it won't spy on
citizens everyday transactions experts
are worried that China's cryptocurrency
will allow greater state surveillance
China's central bank is not the only one
pursuing a digital state backed currency
but it is likely to be the first major
one to launch it beyond replacing cash
this could international eyes
remin be and experts think possibly
create less dependency on the US dollar
there is still a long way before that
happens though most governments are
still wary about crypto the world will
be watching China's experiment closely
[Music]